Steve, I've never met you but I followed your whole life and career.
And out of everything you've done, what I found most inspiring...
...was the commencement speech that you gave at Stanford in 2005...
...where you shared lots of lessons that you've learned throughout your life.
And the one I remembered most is your final lesson around following your heart.
Your time is limited so don't waste it living someone else's life.
Have the courage to follow your heart and intuition.
They somehow already know what you truly want to become.
Steve's legacy is gonna live for a very long time.
The stories are pronounced around his innovation;...
...not just innovation on technology but on business models...
...and in creating a culture of sustainable innovation which we certainly see at Apple,...
...something we try to embody here at EMC.
What can you say about a man that has literally created industries...
...and changed the world; he really has.
He's been such an inspiration to millions of people.